this is the tungsten pendulum Bob this
was one of the first pieces of metal
that we machined for the clock and this
was made for the first prototype either
as a Huygens style pendulum or even as a
torsional style pendulum in a Horgan's
pendulum is the one you probably
recognized as a grandfather style clock
we ended up using a torsional pendulum
which is a twisting pendulum it has a
hole through the center that that has a
little bump in the center that's
actually specific to a one second
Huygens style pendulum and this
particular material is probably one of
the longest lasting materials that we're
using in the clock both because it's
extremely dense and heavy almost as
dense as gold or platinum would be as
well as the fact that it has one of the
highest melting temperatures of any
metal unknown and so this particular
object would probably last in the
hundreds of thousands or millions of
years and that little bump that's in the
center being specific to this materials
expansion rate of based on temperature
actually makes it specific to one second
so an archaeologist finding this many
millennia into the future might actually
be able to determine our basic unit of
time just from this single object alone
so as I said before this is an extremely
dense object and I have with me the
aluminum version that we used to as a
test piece right before we made this
final tungsten one and you can see how
much of an indent the aluminum makes in
the pillow and this is the tungsten
version